so ladies are you ready to host the
oscars yeah we're going to crush this we
just have to do better than last year's
host that is the thing yes totally it is
a competition in that way remember last
year's host god they must have sucked i
bet they got canceled trash oh wait
there wasn't a host last year oh or the
year before let me come on or the year
before oh
boom we're already winning we're nailing
it give it to me okay the oscars live
sunday march 27th hosted by regina hall
amy schumer and wanda sykes on abc
good morning
public programming for 2022 oscar week
is made possible in part by the ruderman
family foundation
which promotes authentic representation
in the entertainment industry and full
inclusion of people with disabilities
throughout all sectors of society
and now
please welcome academy short films and
feature animation branch governors
jennifer ew nelson and bonnie arnold
hello everyone and welcome to the
animated feature presentation for the
2022 academy awards
on behalf of myself jennifer nelson
bonnie arnold and our fellow governor
john bloom we're so happy to finally be
here together with you in the samuel
goldwyn theater
today after two years of being a part
we're finally together appropriately to
celebrate five nominated films with
themes of belonging togetherness trust
family and overcoming division
good morning
so good to be here again as jennifer
said congratulations to all the nominees
we're excited to share their stories
today but a few um kind of fun facts
before we start
this year or i should say 2022 about
from what i understand a couple just two
days ago 20 years ago
the first best animated feature oscar
was awarded to shrek
so 20 years of
and and since then we've had such
amazing growth in the animation industry
our branch is now over 800 members with
three awards animated feature animated
short and live action short
the movies this year are all original
films no sequels yet
all the films were created remotely and
we know why
the locations include colombia southeast
asia italy afghanistan and the good old
usa
we have three nominees from the latinx
community and one film
and one film that was nominated an
animation documentary and international
feature a first
we'll be showing clips of each film each
of the films and jennifer and i will be
discussing those films with with the
filmmakers today i hope you will see all
of the all of the movies in their
entirety and so without further ado
let's get started
[Applause]
encanto
[Music]
50 years ago
in our darkest moment
this candle blessed us with a miracle
and the greatest honor of our family has
been to use our blessings to serve this
beloved community
tonight
we come together once more
as another steps into the light
to make us proud
[Music]
[Applause]
i can't
i need you
come on
let's get you to your door
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
will you use your gift
to honor our miracle
will you serve this community and
strengthen our home
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i understand you
of course they can come
[Music]
[Music]
we have a new gift
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's bigger
[Music]
you wanna go where
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay all right
i think we're going to get the
filmmakers to the stage
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right
i'm sitting over here
well i i sort of have it i'm going to
introduce you to them and
so um first i'm going to start with uh
jared bush who's in the middle here
who's
who's uh one of the directors with byron
howard who could not be here today
jared's credits include the co-director
and screenwriter on zootopia and
screenwriter on
moana
second is yvette moreno the producer
yvette has a 25-year history at disney
and worked on many of the animated films
including big hero 6 tangled and
wreck-it ralph
and she's the first latina nominated in
the feature animation category
congratulations to that
finally at the end clark spencer one of
also one of the producers
clark is the president of walt disney
animation studios and a multiple academy
award nominee for the films you produced
at disney
and an academy award winner for zootopia
and i have to add long time friend
that's right
anyway congratulations to you all on the
movie it looked amazing i loved standing
back there and forgot how great the
sound sounds when it's kind of moving
your body
um let's start with jared jared you and
clark and byron all work together on
zootopia
and this it seems like it's from what i
read it's movie this movie kind of had
its beginnings there can you talk a
little bit about how the idea came to
yeah sure so um so byron and i are
lifelong musicians and even as we were
working on zootopia we said if we ever
do anything
after this movie it has to be musical
and so early on when we're still
finishing up on zootopia
and yvette and i were working on moana
where i was working with lynn lynn
wanted to do the definitive latin
american musical and byron and i wanted
to do a musical so it made so much sense
for us all to sort of figure out what
that might be we needed to figure out
what is this story going to be about
what do we all have in common how do we
find ourselves in the story and we all
had large somewhat dysfunctional
extended families and we said we'd like
to see that on screen um
and do it with many characters typically
we're not able to do that but we wanted
to put that stake in the ground from the
beginning and tell this very large
family story so that's how we started
well jared is talking about lin-manuel
miranda who is the songwriter for the
movie right
and um so he so he had he was working on
on um mulan at the time with with you
guys yeah we were just finishing up on
that there's a little bit of overlap
between those two movies um and it's
okay to work with him he's fine yeah so
i figured doing it again would be okay
yeah and how did you have to pitch him
on this or did you i mean i'm just
curious how you got no you know what's
funny is no one knows how it happened
because i like lin's like yeah well you
guys came to me and i was like well they
came to us and i think what it was is um
we have uh tom mcdougall who's our our
music guru genius i think that he
sort of set us up on a date that we
didn't know that was happening and we
were married at the end of it and we
don't know how it occurred so i think
it's because of him yeah well clark and
all the movies that you've done at
disney this is your first musical was it
how was that different in in a way i
mean with different types of challenges
or was it just appealing to you because
you hadn't done it before well going in
it was appealing because i had never
done a musical i've been with disney
dear vanessa said we've known each other
for a while 32 years at disney animation
and so i had never done a musical and
when they were talking about doing a
musical and doing with lin-manuel
miranda i was like i gotta be on this
project and i will tell you if i'm being
really honest in this room i thought
going in that it might actually be a
little easier because i'd always heard
well one of the great things in a
musical is your songwriter writes a song
the the length of the song is all set
kind of what needs to happen is sort of
set in terms of the storytelling so you
get these song moments and then you can
start putting that into production but
actually it's so much more infinitely
complicated because you gotta record all
the people and there's such an ensemble
in this film to get those songs uh
recorded you gotta get choreographers in
there you gotta think about the camera
moves you gotta all of that just adds
layer to layer to layer but i will tell
you the satisfaction of seeing it come
together is it's just amazing i mean to
be able to think at one point in time
lynn is playing you a demo
over zoom on a friday night and
eventually it's going to be a song in
the film and watching all that happens
it was pretty spectacular this has been
a very special experience well i'm going
to stick with music for another minute
only because we all know the this or we
may not know but this movie has done the
music has just been so popular for the
film and i want to take a moment to give
a special shout out to another old
friend of mine jermaine franco who is
the who's done who did the score for the
movie she's also nominated and she's
also she is in addition she's the first
latina to be nominated for score at in
the academy so very proud of her
um but maybe that had so how did how did
you get jermaine in the mix so uh yeah
jermaine's amazing and we're so so
fortunate to have her on this project
and
uh you know again through tom mcdougall
early on we were looking for
uh you know somewhat for a composer and
and
again her work that she had done i know
she had worked with tom on coco
previously and she had scored other
films and
we
we met her and we just knew right away
that she was just the perfect one and
she has such a gift of
really diving into
uh you know authenticity and the culture
and she went as far as even ordering
specific
musical instruments from colombia and
brought them had him shipped to her
house
and really was just
did an amazing job of of like i said
just diving into and making sure that
the sounds were were uh sounded
colombian and
she somehow i don't know how she did it
but she got an afro-colombian choir to
sing from colombia where she
um you hear you heard it a little bit in
the clip when antonio goes into the room
and you hear the choir and and it really
just brought so much to the film
um speaking of that so so why colombia
in particular and how did you guys go
about
you know
diving in getting the research and
diving into that getting it so much it
seems like there appears to be to me so
much authenticity on the screen in terms
of everything from like you said
starting with the music and i can only
imagine the costumes etc well you know
as jared mentioned early on they wanted
to do a film set in latin america and
really everything at disney animation
starts with research and and diving into
really heavy research and
um you know as as you know
byron and jared kind of really looked
into latin america they really we had
two friends that clark and jared and
byron had from they'd met on zootopia
they were filmmakers um and they were
doing they worked with them doing a
documentary on zootopia and they
happened to be colombian but they uh
were really good friends of theirs and i
i think byron and jared reached out to
them started talking about that they're
like you should really look at colombia
you know and uh there was a research
trip that went down there and
really they found it's such a diverse
country it's a beautiful country and
there's it really is like the crossroads
of latin america and there's so much
diversity within the country within the
people within the music within the the
food and uh and really we fell in love
with the country and then as we started
making it we had another group our
artists were ready our leaders were
ready to go down to colombia of course
our trip was planned for the end of
march of 2020.
so uh it breaks my heart because i was
supposed to go
uh but uh so when that when the pandemic
happened we kind of we knew we had to
shift and how do we bring all of that
what they were going to experience down
there to
to us over zoom and so we created the
the colombian cultural trust and which
was a you know a group of experts of
botanists and architects and juan and
natalie were also one of their
filmmakers and
really just every
single piece of
design every single piece of artwork
went in front of juan and natalie and
really to make sure that we were
representing and
celebrating the country wow
um
this could be for any of you or jared or
whatever but it seems like you
you know
it's specific to columbia but then a lot
of the things in terms of the
storytelling are very universal
so how did you
i don't know if it's i'm just making a
comment or if i'm asking a question but
it just feels like that must be enter
you know
i think i think i mean i think for a lot
of us that that you're seeing today i
think that's that's the goal right you
always want to tell a story that is
specific to that place and those people
at the same time to hit some sort of
universal human condition type story so
that you can read yourself into that i'd
say for this one specifically
our co-director co-writer charisse
castro smith who's amazing has a real
unbelievable grasp of magical realism
and her own personal story she infused
into this story specifically abuela
alma's uh backstory the way that they
had to leave uh their original town and
flee and that was something that was
really important to her to put it in and
she always said you know universality
comes through that specificity as we got
into the characters um we really tried
to look at our own families and family
archetypes and say what
like there's usually a golden child in
the family there's someone who bears the
responsibility when i was growing up my
mother would heal with her food so make
that a real thing and we basically went
through the movie several times and we'd
strip the magic out of it and say what's
the relatable family human story and
then put the magic back in and make sure
that worked and then go back and forth
so basically we as best we could tried
to make it feel like no matter where you
are in the world you can read yourself
into that story if you happen to be
colombian it's different there's many
many small things that many people
wouldn't recognize but we wanted to make
sure if you were colombian you'd see it
and say that's for me that's for me and
that's very specific to their experience
interesting
um
so you had a
i'm going to talk about it about the
cast because it's a really big cast
and i know from having worked in
animation a long time that sends off
major
you know alarm bells
only because in animation of course you
have to build every single character and
um you know there's there's a cost
involved in that obviously but there's
also logistics and just and obviously
with all the pandemics so maybe however
you guys want to address some of that
just uh
you know deciding to tell a story with
that
expanse of a cast and then actually
executing it
what was that i don't know clark and
okay i'll start so to jared and byron's
credit from the beginning they said it's
a family of 12. and we screen our movies
multiple times within our own studio and
people give notes and we would get notes
saying i don't know if i understand this
character or if this character's
developed enough do you really need them
so everyone was trying to figure out how
do they actually edit out characters to
get 12 down to maybe eight or down to
six or something to your point usually
it's a buddy story or there's four
people maybe that you're tracking but
byron and jared were adamant and to the
credit of to both jared and charisse is
the screenwriters they said let us take
that challenge we will figure out how to
make that character be something that
the audience does understand and know
and then through what they were writing
and then through it what lynn wrote song
wise it all started to come together so
it made sense story-wise but then to
your point from a production standpoint
it was a lot to put on the team 12
characters 12 models 12 different rigs
12 different hairstyles 12 different
clothing
all of it had to move all of it had to
feel real
but it was so integral to the film that
that's where we put all of our attention
and detail in the movie we really
focused on that area because again to
their credit they said we're not going
to give up on that let us rise to that
challenge and then we'll figure out from
a production standpoint how to get it
done definitely all 12 of them have to
have a close-up at some point right yeah
of course well the other thing i'd say
is and donna hall's here is um when we
when we were working on moana she
originally had like eight brothers
and that was a great story and then she
got in a boat and we're like i guess
we're not using those eight brothers so
part of what we had to figure out on
this was
if we want 12 family members we also had
to stay around that house and
continually interact with them so early
on figuring this is not going to be a
quest story because we need to continue
to be around that house so that was also
tricky and i think to clark's point in
every
i thought it was going to be simpler too
i'm like it's all one location it'll be
much easier that was not the case um the
other trick i knew the whole time she
was like you're crazy um the other thing
is that all the characters are going
through their own stories and so if you
have the family sitting around a table
you also had to track psychologically
where they were at and then the
animators would go in and have very
specific acting choices for every single
one of those 12 characters so
it turned out to be a lot
and i can only imagine this is probably
a common
uh comment or a question for this all of
the groups we're going to talk to today
it seems like there were probably a lot
of uh voice recordings in people's
basements closets addicts et cetera it
was that
well uh
yeah well for a lot of our scratch we
were fortunate because we were we
started recording a little later in the
pandemic where studios recording studios
were
opening up um and so
uh there were a couple in the homes that
we you know our amazing sound team
figured out how to use
but a lot of it you know so we were able
to do a lot in the studio but everything
was done via zoom you know we the first
time we had met any of our cast in
person was at the premiere because
everything had been over zoom but it was
uh you know it's a ton of work because
people were all over the world
and we had coveted protocols to follow
you know our own uh company protocols
and then the local protocols and
and booking studios and language it was
a bit complicated and we had an amazing
team that uh a shout out to tunde who
was our production office manager who
seamlessly handled it all
i kept checking in are you okay he's
like yeah i got it i got it and he
really
uh i mean really we had you know we were
in london at one point columbia
you know florida nashville new york we
were everywhere northern california and
really just trying to figure it out and
and then we had to do singing and then
you know all of that and so we i felt
like we were constantly constantly in
recording and every time towards the end
we're like okay this is our last one and
then there'd be one more that popped up
okay this is our last one well i think i
think seamless is like the operative
word because you would you never know it
just looks amazing it looks beautiful
and i wish i could go on i have more
questions but we have limited time today
but i just want to thank you all the
movie looks amazing i hope you will all
go
be able to see the movie in its entirety
and um thank you all for coming and
being here today thank you
[Applause]
flee
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
is
i love you
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
i love you
[Applause]
please
[Applause]
wow
such an amazingly powerful film it's um
it's such an honor to be talking to you
about this film today let me introduce
you to the audience so jonas parr
rasmussen the director of the film
you demute in 2006 with your tv
documentary something about haftan
followed by a series of radio
documentaries from all around the world
and your feature film debut searching
for bill which is a mixture of
documentary and fiction
won the nordic docs award at the
international competition prize at dhaka
vive
and in 2015 you premiered your
documentary what he did
so jonas
producer monica hellstrom
you've been a producer at the final cut
for real since 2010
and
produced several films including the
distant barking of dogs which was
shortlisted for an oscar in 2018
nominated for a european film award and
won more than 30 awards including the
best documentary first appearance
um
and uh yes
and we'll talk later about some more of
humanitarian work
cena bureau sorensen oh sorry you're
over at the end
[Laughter]
also producer so it's a two-time oscar
nominee for producing the act of killing
in 2013 and a look of silence in 2016.
and
he's been a producer since 1998 and has
produced documentaries in south africa
zimbabwe senegal thailand indonesia
colombia argentina besides denmark and
sweden
and charlotte de gor della gornere who's
the producer
is also the executive producer and one
of the founders of c of sun creature
denmark and france
and in 2020 sun creatures first feature
film flee
with charlotte as the animation producer
was awarded this deemed con label
so this is a movie of a lot of firsts
this as bonnie was saying before flea
has been nominated for best animated
feature best international film and best
documentary feature for the oscars this
year was the first time in oscar history
it's also the only 2d animated feature
this year is the first animated
nomination for denmark
and interestingly parasite director bong
joon ho said this is the most moving
piece of cinema he saw this year
that's quite a lot of phrase and it's
very powerful especially now
jonas could you talk about your
friendship with amin
i mean his pseudonym i mean and what
caused you to tell his story like this
in animation right now
well i'm i met amin when i was 15. i
grew up in this very
rural danish village
and one day he arrived all by himself
from afghanistan
and stayed in foster care with a family
just around the corner from where i i
live with my family
and um
we started making up at the bus stop
every morning going to high school and
slowly became very good friends
and already back then i was of course
curious about how and why he had come
um but he didn't want to talk about it
and of course respected that um but this
story of his past kind of became this
black box in our friendship and also
within him that
we couldn't open or he couldn't open
um and that's until
nine years ago where he decided that he
wanted to
start sharing his story i had asked him
prior if i could do a radio documentary
about the story
i have a background in radio
and he then said
that he didn't feel ready but he knew
that he would have to share his story at
some point because he felt this kind of
disconnect in his life because he
couldn't
make his past and present connect
but it didn't feel quite ready yet
but when he would be ready would i share
it with me because he trusted me
um
and then
years passed and i was invited for this
workshop in vipol a danish town but as
an animation school uh and where the
workshop is called any ducks where they
invite animators and documentary
filmmakers to develop ideas for
anime documentaries and ask me if i had
an idea and i thought of his story
um and i thought that maybe animation is
a good way to tell his story and we met
up and i asked him
and he was really intrigued by the fact
that he could be anonymous behind the
animation because what you
hear in the film is his real voice
telling his story for the very first
time and you know it's
it's quite harrowing experiences it's
really his life trauma and it's not easy
for him to talk about so the fact that
he didn't have to be
[Music]
public about this and didn't have to be
in a situation like this and you know
small talk about his traumas
um
was really what enabled him to start
sharing his story because he he couldn't
you know
he didn't want to go to work and people
would know his innermost secrets and his
traumas all in the supermarket so doing
this animation was really what enabled
him to start hearing his story and
opening this black box that had been
there for more than 20 years
so in many ways animation was integral
to the process in order to protect his
identity and tell his story as frankly
as possible without hiding too much of
the details
yeah but totally and also because
of course most of the story takes place
in the past so animation was a really
good tool to
make afghanistan and 80's come back
alive and his childhood home in kabul
but also you know it's it's really a
story about memory and trauma and with
the animation it allowed us to be a lot
more kind of expressive about these
things when he started to talk about his
traumas you could sense in his way of
talking that he would slow down
he would become more kind of incoherent
and you could tell that now it's not
about what things look like anymore now
it's about an emotion he has inside
about being angry or afraid or sad
and with the animation it really enables
us to go into that emotion and show that
you know in a more kind of expressive
and surreal way that felt more honest to
the testimony
monica and cena this is a question for
you too actually because you have such a
background in documentary film
and telling people's individual personal
stories what brought you to
create this team to tell the story in
animation and how did that come about
i'll just start out but
so jonas came to us back into 13 with
the story
and
it was very clear from the beginning
that we needed animation
so we actually
contacted
charlotte and the theme when we were set
up by our anime at the animation
film
animation school in weibo
so we started building the team around
and so that was really interesting and
meeting that because in documentary work
in such a different way
we're very much about the story and
that the story getting created also in
editing
and the way of of working together was
like really having to learn a new
language
and and and and find that way of
thinking and working and planning so
that was really exciting and also just
the opportunity of creating and being
creative in a different way it kind of
set us free
right and um your
this film was actually done on a budget
which is a fraction of the other shelves
it's a very expensive documentary but a
very cheap animation film
but sun creatures was actually where all
the animation was done
yeah so we met
i think in 14 um wyoness came at sun
creature um and we are a 2d animation
studio we we created it with six other
creators from uh koplan school in paris
and the animation workshop in denmark
and when eunice and monica came
it was very clear for us that we needed
to surround them to with
write like um to create a visual
language for this film and um
because you know when people come from
documentary and us coming from animation
we don't speak the same language like we
don't know the same festival they like
they don't know and see but i don't know
if like we don't go to the same
commissioner to found uh to found the
project it's not at all the same way of
budgeting so it's really a collaboration
of um them coming with their their their
cook from the commentary com like a
scriptwriters editor uh sound uh and us
um jess and guillaume is we're the art
director
that are here in in the in the room
today with us and kenneth is the
animation director and the lead
storyboard artist so they really was
working very very closely with jonas to
to to try to guide what's how the film
will look like because you know in
animation we must use to do cartoony
things um so we really had to work on
making sure that when people will turn
on the tv they will say okay this is not
for kid
and also um that is um normally in
animation you you it can be very um over
the top you know you and that's what you
learned at film schools you know in
anime at the animation school so
all the the work that the animator had
to do was really to like
be more um
be more subtle and more authentic
um and that's a very it was really good
that uranus and and and candid could
work together where okay eunice was like
because jonas is his first animated
feature you know so
uh it was it was very good to have um
new eyes and like uh okay now here you
could you you can do less you know
because the the movie is very
is very subtle and i think that's coming
from uh i think that's really a
combination of of having jonas directing
and then and having jason kenneth uh
guiding him uh to put that vision into
into animation
um yeah absolutely then he was also the
first time our editor jaeno spielsko
jensen that he worked on animation and
he comes from fiction and documentary he
edited another round that won for
denmark last year
and the hunt and all these films and has
also we've worked a lot with him on on
the documentaries
but but both for us for him and for
moanik and me
learning even how to read an animatics
was a very fantastic experience but a
completely new one and a learning curve
that's amazing um
i have to ask has it means family seen
this film
yeah they've seen the film um and you
know it's not an easy watch for them
because the experiences he had is kind
of
their experience as well and so it's
it's not an easy watch for them but
they're really happy that this kind of
story is being told because they feel
you know
often refugees are defined just by being
refugees so to have a story like his out
there which is a more kind of nuanced
story where he's
yes he was a refugee and what he'd been
through marks him still but you know
he's also a
brilliant academic and he's um
you know gay and he's a cat
lover
and a house owner and
uh someone who had his sexual awakening
watching shangri fandam films back in
80s you know i know that poster yeah
so you know just just give you know a
nuanced
narrative to refugee story so you get
you know you see the human side to it
and not just
someone who's in need
is really important for amin and his
entire family
it's actually very
present in the news right now what's
happening and monica
we were actually talking last night cena
about
the refugees and you're actually helping
some of the families that you'd worked
with before
yeah that's for another documentary film
that's
is
is in ukraine
so and it yeah i've made two previous
films in ukraine so we've been it's had
a lot of focus it's been a bit
schizophrenic to be here
but i think that the theme of my films
in ukraine is also about displacement
and it's a very strong theme in flea so
i can kind of see this journey and also
i think being here with
with flea it opens up a platform to talk
about
that
all refugees are important also people
from afghanistan we gotta help we gotta
remember them
so so that's been an amazing opportunity
to
to keep that focus
what do you feel that's a question for
all of you especially with everything
going on what do you feel that you wish
people would take away after seeing this
film and really seeing inside to sort of
the everyday experience of being a
refugee
but i think the sense of connection you
know that they get connected to someone
you you maybe wouldn't normally identify
with
and see how alike we are and
the importance of listening
and sharing
and how healing that is um
and i think you know with everything
going on right now in in
ukraine you know it's it's a reminder
that
you know all refugees are
our friends neighbors and possible
you know husbands and wives um
and
that we need to see that and and i
really hope you know it's really
wonderful to see how borders open up
right now and and homes and hearts open
up for the ukrainian refugees and i
really hope that's a general change in
how we perceive
refugees in the world in general
whether from ukraine or afghanistan or
syria or myanmar or
wherever
wonderful
thank you so much for this film i mean
the scene where uh meena went to the
club i was given the money was just i
literally wept when i watched that is
such a beautiful film so present today
and i think it's very important for
people to see it so i hope everyone
watches this film is very very powerful
so thank you
lucca
okay everyone this is uh
smooka yeah he's in charge now got it
[Music]
god
[Music]
wow
that was hard to watch
here
come on
[Music]
wait it feels like it's still there yeah
that's called phantom tail you'll get
used to it
right
walking don't worry you're in luck i
basically invented it
to start stack everything one on top of
the other like a pile of rocks
great i mean fine whatever now walking
is just like swimming but without fins
or a tail and also there's no water
otherwise it's like the exact same thing
give it a try
that's not it try it again
oh try to lead with your head
no more belly
that's that's lying on the ground how
about this just take a step without even
thinking about it no no no don't think
about it i don't know how to not think
about something ah okay okay watch point
your feet to where you want to go okay
and then you just
catch yourself before you fall
yeah that's right
good
good
yes
yes i'm getting it
not bad kid albertos
it's a human thing
i'm kind of an expert what does it mean
the thing you just said come on i'll
show you some more stuff
mother of pearl
you live up here yeah me and my dad he's
not even here a whole lot so i pretty
much just do whatever i want isn't it
dangerous yeah it's the best everything
good is above the surface
like
what else
air
gravity also known as
the sky clouds the sun whoa don't look
at it
just kidding definitely look at it
and then
there's human stuff
[Music]
as you can see i've been collecting for
a long time so ask me anything
ah yes that's the magic singing lady
machine it's broken unfortunately
dude you unbroke it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's that oh it's just the greatest
thing that humans ever made
the vespa
whoa you just sit on it and it takes you
anywhere you want to go in the whole
stinking world
fespa is freedom
[Music]
pretty cool right uh
yeah
huh
are you gonna make one i think you have
all the parts
i do have the parts
i am gonna make one you wanna help me
yeah wait no i can't i gotta go home
right this second yeah if my parents
found out i was up here
it would be bad so thank you but
[Music]
goodbye
forever
okay but now i i really do have to go
okay bye
seriously i have to go like now like
right now okay see ya
oh
it's even better than the picture yeah
it is
oh gotta run
see you tomorrow
thank you
[Applause]
thank you
hello everybody so let me introduce you
to the filmmakers uh first is enrico
casarosa the director
[Applause]
hello
enrico has worked on uh has worked at
pixar for about 20 years on some of our
favorite films ratatouille and
coco and his own short la luna
and the
and the andrea warren the producer
welcome thank you thank you she's also
spent more than 20 years at pixar she
started in marketing and then was a
production manager on wall-e and brave
and then co-produced cars 3. so
congratulations thank you
so thank you again congratulations on
your nomination
and i just want to say the movie to me
was the perfect anecdote to lock down
because i got to be an armchair visitor
to italy which made me feel great and
kind of jealous
you know uh enrico i had sort of read
that you know this movie is based on
your childhood friendship
um and um i know that we were talking
the other night andrea was saying that
alberto is actually that is your
friend's name i just was um i'm
wondering it was so moving what you were
talking about the other night i went if
you could share with the audience how
was it when albert when we were able to
show alberto the movie
yeah
it's certainly one of those things you
wish you were
right there by his side we could not do
that but we sent it to him
and so i have this wonderful image that
he described to us we were able to
premiere the movie and go there to italy
in june so we spent time with him and he
had to watch it the day before because
he had to be ready for press which i was
really like oh i wanted to see him react
but he had this wonderful image
he painted for me which was
he saw it with his family
and um his two little kids you know
loved it and they were asking where is
alberto now it's like well
here he is but then he was
he went to
he needed a moment he went to the
bedroom and he started sobbing
and his his wife came to kind of pan him
on the back so i think that's the image
i have and it was really touched and um
and you had lost touch with him for a
while right
yeah he lives in italy um we you know
yeah it's easy to
to have these amazing friendships and
then not pick up the phone so you know
from from day one we were saying like
it'd be great if the end of this movie
will make everybody want to pick up the
phone you know and and
that happened a lot maybe in the
pandemic i think a lot of people
connected with people either
on the phone or zooms and you know
without something better to do so it's
kind of a love letter to that to me it
is i i mean it was fun for me to be sort
of an onlooker as i had mentioned um
because um we the one little trip that
we did get to go on for press usually
you kind of go around
in different countries promoting the
film and just because of the pandemic we
weren't able to do that but the one
place we were able to go which was which
mattered the most was italy and it was
so fun to be there with him in person
that was the first time i'd gotten to
meet him and to me it was just um you
know the film is a love letter to italy
but it's definitely a love letter to
friendship and those friends that change
our lives and i think it was so
wonderful to just be an onlooker and see
that reconnection happen i think between
you and alberto and um to to see that
the film itself gave back to that
original friendship by reconnecting you
it was a very roundabout way to meet
again
let's make a five year you guys were
just honestly you were so you were
jumping off into the water and joking
and it was just fun to see that
connection in the kernel of that
friendship
um let's talk a little bit about the
italian part i i also read well i first
of all i loved your um your italian song
needle drop playlist and i was reading
about a little bit about the film enrico
and i think you you put together a list
of that for
was it for inspiration
and you know did some of those make them
make it into the film or how did that
how did that work because i love those
songs yeah you you know
as a filmmaker you really try and
immerse yourself with so much music in
general from score to a needle drop and
you know when we make our reels
animatics of course we're using scratch
music um so but but from day one i knew
this was a stand by me like movie let's
go back to childhood let's spend a
summer
with these kids and i knew that just
like
those kind of movies just they need us a
song the songs of the summer so
um the 50s and 60s in italy are so
wonderful there's of course this
influence from from the us but there's
all these amazing artists so
we kept on listening to them we would
try
five different versions on the montage
of a certain song or this song or the
other
um the one that stands out is probably
the the one in the montage of their
friendship building which is
which is the cat and the fox there's
this whole pinocchio side to that song
that always felt very fitting because in
many ways alberto is the cat on fox in
one
maybe not as negative but but he will
lead you to some trouble
and they are themself a little bit you
know of course
going down this road together so that
and that one interestingly was from 1971
the year i was born which was breaking a
rule for for a while we were looking for
alternatives we should be more in the
50s and 60s
um
and and then we just said like let's
just go for it it just feels right and
you know
it was um
but there's just so many others
uh
helped set the tone i think for the yeah
and and there's such joy in those summer
uh hits um it takes you to to a
different time in a weird way you know
it's 50s but it's also a little timeless
right right
um i guess so sea dragons play a big
role in this see monsters see dragons or
whatever but again i was reading maybe
you could share a little bit of some of
the inspiration for the design of how
did you come up with the
you know
the designs for the
versions of the of the characters that
are sea dragons or sea monsters
yeah the main inspiration was these
really ancient maps there's the carta
marina um
which was kind of one of the first
thoughts that i had like
i want to see those those strange uh
right there there's leviathans krakens
um and the kind of design um
that it's really you can tell it's
grouping other animals it's making them
a little more monstrous there's
obviously some sightings that don't
really you know that must have been a
walrus but it turns into this other
thing and the beautiful design
illustrative sense of that
of those
maps really inspired us in design so we
didn't want to be
uh just you know realistic we wanted to
be more illustrative
and
in a way in the whole movie we looked at
ways to bring some of the 2d inspiration
some of the handmade textures and the
warmth of of 2d so that felt like the
perfect inspiration like old
illustrations ink drawings
and all these you know kind of fins that
the monsters have and in our way we we
gave the more ancient finns that were
closer to carter marina to grandma and
then we kind of said like oh maybe that
you know slowly they're getting a little
more
modern so luca and alberto have a little
less
and then the other thing that was
important is also allowing character to
really speak to for example alberto is
much more sharp fins a little bit of a
more powerful kind of fish inspiration
um
we wanted him to be a little dangerous
so there was a lot of that kind of
thinking behind it i think that you got
to see in the clip um an example of the
transition between
them being the sea monsters and then
becoming human and um andrea what was
that i mean i'm sure that was a a bit of
a technical challenge even for pixar it
was it was probably one of our biggest
things i think um because i mean our
technical teams would kind of ask like
can you do it behind a bush or like
somewhere else
no no no it had you know it had to be
you know right in the same and in water
i have to add yeah exactly and moving
and dripping and and all the the tricky
things all rolled into one so yeah we
said it has to be front and center and
you know i think we wanted that
inspiration of sea dragon and that
clarity but we want we never wanted that
transformation to feel icky you know and
so it we wanted to have it feel playful
and it was really fun i feel like some
of the first tests that were really
convincing were from animation when they
really showed sort of almost this wave
going through his body and so that was
really fun to experiment with sort of
like how does it feel for luca to go
through this and i mean and also this is
the first time this character has
experienced this so not only is it this
new thing we're witnessing this magic
but the character is going through it
for the first time so there was just a
lot of layers to play with in that
moment but
everybody did such a beautiful job you
know bringing those elements together it
was a really i feel like that's part of
what to me is so fun and so rewarding
about animation is that collaboration
between storytelling and technical you
know possibility and and how you mesh
all those things together so that was
one of our big fun early challenges yeah
it was i was also reading a little bit
and i think you can see that the the
design and the look of this is a little
more simple maybe in some ways than some
of the past
pixar films can you both speak to that a
bit i mean you know that
to me it always looks amazing first of
all i just you get involved in the story
you hardly notice but
and overall is that sort of a new
direction based on different different
types of storytelling or just i think it
was one that fit this story i think we
liked that idea that you sort of fall
into a postcard you know and so we're
trying to capture the spirit of the
place and not less the exact detail do
you want to talk about and more about
that enrico that was your aesthetic
i mean yeah
there were a few a few things one it's
really the things
that i love and that i'm attracted to
but
it was a
world of kids
we wanted to be as expressive and
playful as possible with uh so it went
from the texture on their um you know
rouge on the on the cheek i wanted to
stay away and from anything that felt
too smooth or or um
perfect i think the computer
unfortunately does that quite well so we
were trying to break up and bringing a
lot of um imperfection and a sense of
warmth from the more handmade textures i
love watercolor so we always kind of try
and put map map things like that on it
but i think really it went all the way
into the animation style which was so
much fun to think about like how do we
break a little bit the box of what we've
done
um this is a more playful the characters
are a little more playful in design
um we can push the the the the style and
it's much more snappy inspired by some
limited animation
we watch together with animators some of
the things that we really love and
started thinking together how can we do
something different and you know we
watched
animation and fours from you know 1980s
future boy corner and was one of the
things that we were looking at at run
cycles how does that you know the
limitations sometimes bring up such
interesting
uh things so it made us hold poses a
little more and then snap into others
um it made us really just try and break
a bit go to the limit of breaking the
the the rig
um and yeah it really we were asking
ourselves where can we bring this
beautiful you know handmade feel to
everywhere in the movie from the sets to
the characters to the way they move
i just hear
[Laughter]
it i know you worked on a number of
films at pixar but this is your your
first time directing i mean you were
working with some
we know some of the you know on great
films with great filmmakers like brad
bird and lee unkridge and
whatever but how was it to take on your
this film i know you did a short
directed short on your own but to take
on one of these features was it uh
yeah
what were the big challenges in this you
know sort of a bigger role for me yeah
the the interestingly the experience of
the short was like i boarded it
um and we made it
and it was so smooth
so i was completely unprepared for it
for a feature which is the complete
opposite you board it and it doesn't
work and you reward it and your board so
um
i i equate it to you set out with this
wonderful
ship into the sea and you're you have no
idea what's going to be around the
corner and it's a lot of storms and and
it's a lot of ups and downs um
the difficulty of course so i came from
a very visual
place so working finding the right
collaboration with writing was certainly
something that i had to learn
um
and then really
um being more of luca it was also like
how do you direct
treasuring collaboration
um but still leading so that was a
really interesting um you know journey
for me there was so much growth and
that's really what's wonderful about
making some something like this you you
will be in trouble at some points and
then okay how do i get better at this
how do i communicate better how do i
um how do we in the room together come
up with a better solution that i could
come by myself
so that was you know a lot of challenges
i think it's really mostly in story also
telling us smaller stories not it's not
easy we were really trying to stay
intimate talking about these two kids
and of course julia
coming a little bit in between them um
having a different scope and with silly
goals or or drive that sometimes is a
little bit childlike was an interesting
challenge because sometimes you wonder
like well do you need something you know
more driving so there was
wanting to do something different it's
always a little bit uh challenging but
also exciting because i think the crew
gets excited so we had such a good time
with the luca crew was so
appreciative of really being led in into
the filmmaking uh together really yeah i
had one other i was curious in the in
you know it's a personal story of your
you know your own this is your story and
whatever was it was it a hard sell i
mean did you have to pitch it to the
pete doctor and the team and yeah i mean
just in terms of how it might you know
because it is
yeah it's it i still pinch myself a
little bit like wow you made this huge
you know production about this small
little friendship i feel about you yeah
it's it's it's quite wonderful i feel
very lucky with that i think what makes
it again is still against specific
specificity authenticity to universality
right i think
it's from day one i could tell when i
pitched this idea of like what if
there's two friends yes there was the oh
i had a troublemaker friend or oh i was
a troublemaker or isn't it interesting
that friendships in friendships are
opposites attract
and on top of that this idea of like
what if you had to hide sea monsterness
um i remember pete doctor thinking like
oh during puberty i felt i felt that way
i felt i was like
every day changing something you know
the the the whatever difference or
feeling of shame you might have growing
up
my my best friend and i were very nerdy
and very socially inept and
um
this one it so that connected right away
and i think that's what enabled us to
kind of say this will talk to other
people because everyone will project
their own
underdog you know the underdog thing
this is of course you know the other
love letter it is it's a leveler to
underdogs yeah yeah it was fun to like i
think um again that collaboration that's
so fun is everybody bringing their own
stories you know and people would
animate shots even and say oh this
reminds me of this time and they would
tell a story and it was just really fun
to bring all that forward and get it to
put it on the screen you know right well
it definitely definitely shows in the
film and it's really lovely so
congratulations again i wish we had more
time but i hope you'll all see luca and
uh congratulations to you thank you
the mitchells versus the machines
[Applause]
[Music]
well
i guess this is it
oh yep
hey dad you subscribed to my youtube
channel thanks i'm surprised you even
figured out how
katie please after all that i'm a
computer expert
you know uh no problem at all
thanks it means a lot to me
hey don't let the world make normal
while i'm gone okay i never will
i'll call you every week deal raptor
bash
[Laughter]
[Music]
goodbye you king of kings
thanks for being the best mom in the
world we love you honey oh in here
to remember us
every horrible picture we've ever taken
thanks it's it's heavy
i know
wish we didn't
have to go but uh
good luck uh
finding your people
dad come on
you guys are my people
so you know
when i'm sad to be alone
i'll always have
my favorite thing
[Music]
do you remember how moose says i love
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow you're supposed to be sad
come here
[Music]
mom you're hugging too tight you love it
you love it
i did love it
[Music]
thank you
congratulations to you all amazing funny
heart-wrenching film so thank you let me
introduce you to the audience michael
riondo who's the co-director i mean
sorry co-writer and director of the film
and also the voice of aaron
michael has uh made short films
everybody dies in 90 seconds way back in
it since been employed by pixar and jib
jab taught at cal arts worked at disney
television where he served as a writer
and creative director for the annie
award winning tv show gravity falls
phil lord and chris miller are the
producers of the film and of course the
oscar-winning
um prolific producers and directors for
um many many films and they were behind
spiderman into the spider first a lego
movie
21 and 22 jump street
cloudy with a chance of meatballs live
action and animation films all over the
place
so congratulations thank you
and kurt albrecht the producer is um
was formerly the vice president of
physical production at sony
and is has worked on the planning
budgeting and supervision of all the
projects and development at the studio
amazing funny and very real movie about
sort of the relationships in this family
and
apparently this is all based on your
family why did you do that to them and
do they speak
no my dad uh this microphone is very
loud i'm sorry um but my dad is like did
you have to make it look exactly like me
the guys at the elks club are giving me
a hard time um so uh he's but he's
ultimately i have photo documentation
that he did cry during the movie and
which he still apologizes about he's
like i'm sorry you had to see that
it's a tough it was a tough night and
i'm like like like someone died or
something
um but um but no he was uh they're
they're both really moved and my mom
is uh and dad are in town and they're
like running around like uh jackrabbits
and my mom will tell anyone within eight
seconds of meeting them i don't know if
you know but my son's been nominated for
academy awards so he's right here
um so she's making a lot of friends um
and uh
and they're a delight so it's it's it's
been really wonderful to um it's been
really wonderful because it really is a
tribute to them because you know this
moment where um they're leaving me off
at school i had that moment um and i i
it was like
i was like they were leaving and it was
like kind of awkward and they're like so
how's the weather oh my god what are we
gonna do um and then when they were
leaving i like ran after the car and i
called them i'm like could you come back
because i thought i'd be happy because i
was leaving and i was free but instead i
was like all of a sudden filled with
in the at the last possible second
gratitude
this this film uh is the most expensive
therapy
since freud
that's amazing um i think that's one of
the reasons why the relationships feel
so real because and beneath all the
jokes and beneath all the sort of the
amazing visuals there is a really
personal father and daughter story
obviously this is not a father-daughter
situation with you and your family but
um that that connection that you have
with your family is very resonance in
the film so i hope they enjoyed it yeah
no i think they did and and it's and
it's so like i mean it started out as a
story about my family um but i think ev
all of us have had that experience of
telling your parents like oh i'm gonna
be an artist and being like oh no but
they're like smiling like great
um and and i think that everyone sort of
tapped into that in their own way like
you know lindsey oliveiras is in the
crowd what's up bluesy um she's a
production designer um and guillermo
martinez had a story also in the crowd
what um but um but they also had the
same story as as i did and as chris and
phil did and and i think you know they
all brought their own specificity to
whether it's like
lindsay he's like oh i drew on my own
pants and or the you know we have a
wonderful crew of lgbtq plus filmmakers
and they're like what you know what she
was like us and and everybody sort of
added to it and i think we found that
the more specific it got the more people
could see themselves in her
that's amazing um chris and phil so
you've had the choice of doing whatever
project you want obviously live action
or animation
but what spoke to you blew it on this
[Laughter]
but what spoke to you about this story
and this
how it's told and the way that it's been
created um well we met mike when he was
uh working on this in the very early
stages while we were finishing up uh
spider-verse
and he was in uh he and jeff his
co-writer were in
the same office that we were in when we
made our first uh feature cloud with a
chance of meatballs and
they seemed like kindred spirits and
their offices was the same messy it was
even but there was only one of him yeah
um and uh and
we got to know him he was obviously a
funny personal person we got to see what
he was working on and and we could see
first of all he seemed like us uh 10
years earlier and that he had a
manifesto on the wall of how he's going
to change animation and make the
greatest film ever made and we're like
hit this passion and look at his
excitement and as someone who wants to
do something new and different and push
boundaries and that was that's our whole
bag uh in in this business and we
thought well maybe we can just suck out
his life force and stay young forever it
didn't work their hair is thicker and
i'm completely bald
i was bald when we started this
that was in the contract that you were
gonna be a human dorian gray painting
they had to do the quickening at the
beginning of every year yeah
but we uh we had a we had an instant
bond and he's
a total maniac and uh in the best way
and in the same way that we are and so
we
uh we all decided to get together and
and you make this uh
as special and unique and new of a film
as possible and and for how wild the
the movie was when we came on it had the
thing that he described to you and that
we just watched it had the germ of
something that was super personal that
was deeply emotional and it's what all
these movies that we're talking about
today have they have that thing that
makes you
want to make the whole movie
that's amazing and do you feel that your
background doing both live action
animation sort of lets you
push a film like this outside kind of
the box of the expected it does things
that are completely new
visually and tonally yeah i mean luckily
we had this a lot of the same crew that
we had on spider-verse where we had sort
of broken all of the pipeline of how a
cg animated movie is made and nobody
wanted to go backwards and mike had a
very strong vision of what he wanted the
film to look like and we were there to
sort of push him to make it even
wilder and more different because it was
really exciting because animation can
look like anything you can imagine it
doesn't have to all look the same and so
and so it was an opportunity where
people were like yes we want to do this
and you know there weren't as many
people uh saying no which usually is
what happens and so
uh and anybody who said i don't know we
would just sort of tackle and keep
running forward until uh until we got to
have something that that felt uh wholly
unique
and uh kurt there's there's so much of
your background of being able to make
things happen
somehow from a land the plane so to
speak um with the complex sort of
pipelines i'm sure of this film with the
2d and the 3d and the inner life of
katie and all the little emoji things
coming around her head
how was it for you stepping into
producing for this film what was it like
for you it's a piece of cake
[Laughter]
no mike
early on i was helping on the project
before i was a producer and mike's
passion and vision and jeff's too were
just
infectious and that
is really what made me want to work on
it in the first place but then it was
his he had specific ideas about looking
bringing lindsay she's out there
bringing her art to life so we had
really good targets for a lot of what we
were trying to do and then having
these two
it doesn't hurt to have them on your
corner you know so but it was it was
really bringing
the team together building a really
great team with mike and as chris said
we got a lot of the the the vfx team
from spider-verse to be on our movie so
it was evolving the tools from
kind of bringing a comic book to life to
bringing lindsay's art to life
and they were they were down for the
challenge and really leaned into it and
and supported us it was you know it was
a really a pretty great experience we
had our bumps but it was
it was a great it was a really described
experience
yes
in detail
what kurt is too modest to say is you
know he
created an environment where the
creative and all this messiness was not
a liability kurt understands that that
is the engine that drives the entire
show so when the meeting's running late
because somebody had a weird idea and we
have to change the whole scene
he's there for it and he's like let's
push the next meeting let's get this
right because this is the stuff right
right that's a thank you phil
it's true
it is true
that is rare and you have to be very
experimental with the look i mean was
this something that you're just coming
up with as you're you're conceiving of
the film that you wanted to show all
this
inner life i think it's one of the
reasons why the film looks very present
it was something that
i don't know just seems very um you know
kids might understand
[Laughter]
um yeah no i mean i think that you know
we initially got really excited about
just like what if we meld 2d and 3d you
know just sort of as artists when you're
sitting around and talking but the thing
that sort of made it make sense is it's
like a couple things is that it actually
tracked to the thematics of the story
where it's like the story is about
finding a balance between you know
looking to the past and being nostalgic
like rick is and looking to the future
and being um and being sort of uh and
sort of only looking to the future like
katie is in the beginning and by the end
they're both the same way and they're
growing together and i think with the
art style we're sort of looking to the
past in terms of like 2d animation and
illustration and lindsey's drawings and
and sort of all of the you know markers
and watercolors and then trying to mix
that with the most
you know futuristic technology that you
know we have um and sort of like so
we're trying to find a balance between
that in the story you know the
characters are and then we're also
trying to find a balance that in the art
style and the music and the whole movie
i mean another thing was just trying to
make every frame feel human because it's
a movie about humans and a celebration
of humans and their flaws and and that
sort of thing and and lindsay was really
wonderful at making sure that like every
frame you felt that and whether that was
because the characters had a line around
them or whether a 17 year old was
drawing all over the screen
um and it was very fun to take this like
million dollar
beautiful pristine animation and then
just graffiti all over it um and uh and
and and but it was that's also like the
type of thing you would do when you were
17 because you don't you're like forget
the rules i don't care you know and it
was wonderful to have all of the artists
take that spirit and say like what was i
remember what it was like to make my
first film and to feel like there's no
rules and no limitations like let's do
that you know and everyone had that
spirit and it was it was really
wonderful because of that because then
you could sort of all the ideas were
good it was like what if we do this and
it's like yes put it in the movie great
wonderful you know um because it was you
had that spirit of
of like what if this was our first time
because it was
we didn't have to pretend
i think too shout out to these guys for
being open to listening to everyone's
ideas because that's not always the case
you know and it was we'd have
story artists or animators or designers
and like ever there was contributions
from the entire team it was it was
really great
and uh and mike had a very sort of clear
vision of where he wanted it to go and
so we could show everybody what success
looked like so like if people were
pitching ideas they weren't just
pitching wildly any idea goes because
sometimes you have something what if
it's a drama exactly
yeah and sometimes you have something
that's great but doesn't quite fit in in
the movie but luckily you know a lot of
the a lot of the ideas people had a
clear idea of what was going to work and
so i think that was great and with the
what we called katie vision the little
katie's filigree
on top of it it really only worked when
it was giving you a window into how she
was feeling when we would try putting it
on shot to sort of like ah we'll do some
squiggles here and it just felt gimmicky
and it actually distanced you from the
movie so we would take it out of those
spots and only really use it when it was
there to sort of accentuate sort of
katie letting you know her inner life
that's amazing and so did you have these
essentially writer's room story artist
sessions where you're coming up with all
these gags together
i mean it's every moment yeah
that's the thing like you're like it
never it never stops
we're writing on the mix stage
you know and in the animation reviews
and it's just endless and that is
maddening but it's also like so
beautiful
because you're inspiring one another and
getting to places you wouldn't expect so
who came up with dog pig loaf of bread
um that was that was me
my sister um had a dog named monchi
similar to the dog on my socks and the
dog on the screen little bit little tiny
bit on the screen there um but um but he
uh and monchi was sort of like a um
looked very much like a dog in a piccolo
or loaf of bread it was hard to tell um
and then we put that in the movie and
then sort of like through the process of
iteration realize like oh that was a
really memorable moment maybe you know
and also trying to think of like okay if
the character was smart they would
remember this and then they would bring
it back at the end and this could be
like its shield or whatever so um and
but but it's really true what they were
saying because like if you you know
looking at that scene that we just saw
guillermo came up with a bit where rick
is screaming and hitting the keyboard
and and you know jeff came up with the
line you know jeff came up with the
moose and and chris and phil you know
had the oh we should do a moose call and
stuff like that so there there's like a
lot of every moment you see in the movie
is touched by so many different artists
um and it was it was a joy and it's also
nice because it makes us look good
[Laughter]
because it's like wow there's a lot of
good ideas in there and then it's like
look at all the you know and it's but it
was because we had all these wonderful
artists and i think that's what makes
you know a movie magical right is that
you it's just like a regular magic trick
like if somebody's doing like sleight of
hand you like what you don't know is
they've spent like
two years
training their fingers to do this thing
and practicing endlessly so much so that
you can't believe it there's no part of
your humanity that can imagine the
amount of hours that went into that
sleight of hand and it's the same on a
movie you just don't
realize we want to say that like there's
like one solitary genius that like
dreamed it up in their brain and just
came spilled out of them that you might
be able to write a song that way you
can't make a movie that way making a
movie is a team sport and why it feels
magical because so many beautiful brains
worked on it for so many darn hours
yes it's amazing
on that note we're sadly out of time
we'd love to just keep chatting about
this with you guys forever but
congratulations thank you so much
thank you thank you guys
raya and the last dragon
[Applause]
chief verona we're running out of room
we need to expand to the mainland and
how do you propose we handle the drone
general
without proper protection it would be a
death sentence for our people i might
have a solution for that mother
my little morning mist oh it's good to
see you home
i located raya she's out stealing gem
pieces what
i'd like to take the royal army and
intercept her in spine
well if she's going into spine
i doubt there'll be much left of her to
intercept she's more capable than you
realize
we have to stop her
walk with
me look around
we made all this by making smart
decisions not emotional ones
we are safe
our canal protects us from those
monsters
i don't think it's wise to risk yourself
when you don't have to
but you heard the general we're running
out of space we need to expand if we had
all the gem pieces we could do that
safely
you're right this isn't an emotional
decision it it's the only decision we
can make to secure fang's future
namari
you're truly growing into the leader i
raised you to be
general aditya ready the royal army for
my daughter's command
thank you mother i won't let you down
sorry buddy i got this did you just
throw a shrimp at me that's not even
edible
do you want to play hide and seek
all right ready
one
two
thanks two and a half
three
[Music]
remind me to never have kids
being people is hard yep
six
seven
[Music]
you have small heads no tails you lie to
get what you want like the talon chief
back there yeah well the world's broken
you can't trust anyone
or maybe the world's broken because you
don't trust anyone
you sound just like my bar well he
sounds like a smart man
yeah he was
i really wanted to believe him i really
wanted to believe that we could be
kumandra again
and we can literally thousands of people
turn to stone would argue otherwise that
doesn't mean you shouldn't try and i did
and you know what happened
i got kicked in the back by someone who
gave me a gift
look around
we're a world of orphans because people
couldn't stop fighting over a gem want
to know why other dragons didn't come
back
it's because people don't deserve them
but you can change that no cece i am
done trying kumandra is a fairy tale the
only thing important to me now is
bringing my bob back
um
i think we're in spine
hey
mykaji don't go anywhere i'll be right
back
[Music]
come back please wha what are you doing
i'm going to show you that you're wrong
how by getting squashed by a bunch of
spine rage heads no
by proving to you that if you want to
get someone's trust you have to give a
little trust first
in hindsight
maybe i was a little hasty
but uh who's hungry now i'll leave you
alone
where are you guys
[Applause]
hey guys
congratulations
let me introduce you to the group so don
hall we go way back
he made don made his directorial debut
for disney animations 2011 winnie the
pooh
and went on to direct big hero 6 which
won an oscar for best animated feature
film he also served as co-director of
moana an executive producer for the
upcoming disney series baymax
thank you
carlos lopez estrada the other director
is
actually
mainly in live action right
so he followed his debut film blind
spotting following his uh debut film
blind spotting in 2018 um
he was selected for variety's 10
directors to watch in 2018. his second
film summertime 2020 premiered opening
night at sundance
well it was an amazing film it's so
beautiful and um
it's it's so funny with a very very warm
and touching message so what was it like
with the two of you i mean you don't
have as much of a background in
animation whereas you do have a great
deal of background how did you work out
together that you wanted to create this
film
you're gonna go first
yeah yeah sure
uh i i came into the animation world i
mean i i
i come from independent filmmaking so i
had done a lot of animation
um just growing up with friends and in
film school and then i got to do some
music videos and some commercials but
nothing of the scale
and i remember very well the day that
we joined the project i i pulled don
into a an office at disney animation
freaking out
and i was like look don i don't know how
to make these movies like the only
reason
that i will ever agree to take on this
on this role is if
if you just officially become my mentor
today
and he looked at me he said yeah i would
love nothing more and and that was the
start of a really beautiful friendship i
told them the secret the dirty little
secret is that none of us know how to
make these movies
so just
let's just we'll just one step at a time
yeah but obviously you guys worked it
out somehow so in many ways probably
your background that's different from
the usual path probably helped you i
think the dynamic and it was not i mean
it was definitely don and i but it was
also our two writers adele and qui
they have very
specific and different backgrounds cui
comes from from writing plays and and
doing a lot of martial arts
uh adele comes from she had just written
crazy rotations and and really all of
our backgrounds
uh were so diverse and and all of a
sudden we were in this room together
where we were trying to put
a little piece of ourselves into the
film and trying to challenge how we
would do things don i think comes from
incredible experience and animation
uh and i would i would try to bring a
little bit of my live-action
sensibilities in cui has also very
strong
uh comedy and action voice and i
remember every meeting every story
meeting was just
how can we complement each other how can
we challenge each other and how can we
take this movie that on paper
is is something that you've seen
potentially many times it's an an epic
it's a period piece it's a
a story
about it takes place in a legendary
fantasy world and it brings
many tropes
and the challenge for us was how can we
put ourselves into it in a way that's
gonna make this movie feel fresh and
different and exciting and surprising
and that was really i think how we
approached every step of our
collaboration i think what also helped
and uh phil kind of uh touched on it is
that um
uh well mike you're right these mics are
really hot i'm gonna have to hold it out
here uh the um
we all knew the theme of the movie
right and that was our true north we all
knew what this movie was about it was
about trust and everything was going to
funnel through that and so even though
you know we had a room full of you know
a lot of diverse um backgrounds and
opinions we all knew the movie we were
making and we knew the theme of the
movie so um it
the collaboration actually was very easy
because of that
don is good at many things but
i think his his uh
his true mastery of story and being able
to like have laser sharp vision on on
how to make sure that there's room for
creativity but it's all servicing sort
of like that north star it was something
that to me was very impressive to be
around just because i mean he's been in
this world for uh so so long and
there's not a comment on your age no no
go ahead it's i'm only 53 but i feel
like i'm like 150. uh
don has this incredible ability
at just like remaining true to the heart
of the story and the core and i know it
sounds so easy to say but when you're
in as everyone else was mentioning
before if you're in these
crews of uh our crew is 500 plus
you're in these rooms with sometimes 30
40 50 people that all have incredible
creative ideas
but but i think the ability to just
always always hang on to
the the soul of a project
um it's it's something that i saw in
practice and that i'm just i think very
fortunate to have had him as my partner
in this it's a superpower
it's a superpower because otherwise how
do people know how to give you
ideas how do they collaborate if they
don't know what you're trying to achieve
so it is definitely probably the most
important thing for a director to be
able to do
but how did you when you're talking
about this world that you're creating
how did you come up with this unique
place that we're basically traveling
through all the different aspects of it
over the course of the film
um what about it
really drew you to it
um well so the project's been going on
for you know in in development for quite
a while uh before we came on about a
year and a half before uh release um and
so though there were sort of tentpoles
that were always there you know it was
going to be a film that was going to be
inspired by the many different cultures
of southeast asia you know that was a
tentpole
um this world defined by a river in the
shape of a dragon called kumandra that
is that is five different lands that was
once won but now has been broken into
five different lands that was always
sort of there
um
and i think for us like the first day we
got together and and started you know
batting around ideas you know that theme
of trust i think came day one
and and it gave us that sort of north
star um
but the other thing that to me that i
kept holding on to was
just despite the bigger thematic
elements that we're dealing with despite
that oddly weirdly
uh
unintentionally the movie was reflecting
what was going on in real life
it really boiled down to a very simple
story about this this young woman who
just wants to get her father back and
she's been you know
she had a traumatic experience when she
trusted somebody and it went sideways
and it cost her her father and she just
wants him back and it you know we could
keep kind of going back to that human
story because i think i think
everybody's kind of touched on it in
some way that that is something we all
have in common now you know maybe our
parents didn't get turned into stone by
weird cloud monsters but we all have you
know some some version of of that story
that we can and you know imprint
ourselves on
right i think another aspect of it that
i think is important to bring up is oh
it's not sure who's our producer she's
not here today
she'll be there tomorrow
but
but she
she was able to compile an incredible
team
not only in our crew but also the people
who are supporting the vision and the
people who are supporting all the
cultural aspects of the movie the movie
as don mentioned is inspired by the many
cultures of southeast asia and in order
to do that
accurately we will first of all needed
to surround ourselves with crew members
who were from the region and could speak
from from a very personal
point of view to what it what it's like
to experience life there and then we had
our team similarly to the encanto team
we had a saudi station story trust which
was comprised of anthropologists
architects musicians dancers
martial arts people
who who were there from like the very
very first day of production and into
marketing and into like just throughout
the entire process
and they were essentially a key part in
building the world and making sure that
every decision big or small these are
like character traits these were
locations but these were also like the
the textures of the fabric and the
patterns on dresses just making sure
that we were building it with them
and that we were like
accurately
allowing all the inspiration from all
this lance yvette was talking a second
ago about latin america and i realized
that there's so much connection with
with
i was born in mexico city with how latin
american countries see each other and
southeast asian countries see each other
even though there's you know they're
different entities with very unique
identities and and very unique cultures
there is this sort of like umbrella
there's like this sense of a family
between uh all of us and there's
something that unites us with stronger
than us and i i think that
just having all of these voices from all
these countries pitching in constantly
throughout the process
is what in my opinion makes the movie
feel so rich and
and just so unique i've never seen a
world like that on on a film before and
i think we're all very proud of that and
there are multiple research trips as
well to to the region and like like in
kanto and like yvette we didn't get to
go on any of them so
we share that
our press tour which i think we were
hoping you would get to travel all over
southeast asia finally uh our prester
was from our
kitchen table to our dining room table
to our
busy though thanks covered
[Laughter]
well how did you work with the um how
did you work with the voice cast because
i heard that there was a lot of ad
living and a lot of the personalities
that come out
so clearly um talk a little bit about
what that was like yeah i mean well
aquafina i mean you know she's she's
known for just having really strong
improvisation skills and we could use
them maybe a tenth of it you know we
recorded so much
um uh she's brilliant um all of the apps
most of it was r-rated yeah there's some
really
i i wish i wish we could it'd be amazing
[Laughter]
um
like all the actors actually you know we
give them as much you know room to play
ultimately that's kind of what
you want to do right like just you know
because it's hard i i think people don't
understand
how difficult it is for actors to do
voiceover work because you know they're
used to having a scene partner right and
they're used to having sets and well
sometimes green screen but you know that
there's at least some some physical
thing there um that they're reacting to
and with us it's just all imagination
you got a page of script and
you have me
who's terrible like reading with the
actor you know he really is terrible i'm
really bad and i'm really bad that's why
i'm not an actor um but uh
but that so it's hard you know and they
and you know they don't
a lot of times you know because they
come in multiple times it's not like
you know they they do the whole movie we
bring them in you know five or six
different sessions and the first thing
we do is talk about okay well here's
what's changed in the movie this time
and you know you kind of have to update
them because as as phil and chris said
and mike that everything's changing all
the time and we're used to that that's
that's you know
that's a normal tuesday for us but like
for for other mediums it's a little
tricky so um you just try and create a
space to just to have fun and play and
and all the actors were really good at
improving and but i mean kelly marie
one of the first sessions we had
we um there's a moment in the scene the
the film where
it's the last stop for ryan this is it
if sisu is not here
then it's it's despair you know and uh
we had written or we had written a short
little kind of kumandran prayer and um
we got in the room and and she did it
and it was beautiful and she's like hey
um can i try something which as a
director is like
you love that you know i love hearing
can i try something because it means
they're invested and they have a
creative idea and so absolutely
and she ad-libbed um a much longer
version of that confession we call it
the confessional really because it's and
it was about her vulnerability and about
how long she's been looking for
uh
you know sisu and and it was just this
really and not really believing if sisu
is even real you know
in this little couplet that she
ad-libbed there was just so much
vulnerability and emotion and we were
crying and it was day one you know of of
our our partnership with kelly marie but
it was like man so so the ad-libbing
wasn't just comedic but it was also you
know in in some of the more dramatic
moments as well i remember that day we
finished that recording session don gave
me a ride
and we just got into his car and shut
the doors and there was just silence
like really really long silence and we
just looked at each other like
yeah
yeah
and nothing else was said it was just
drove in silence and i think for
for many people myself included not not
having done a
feature animated film before there's
this misconception that
actors in animated movies
come into the booth record some lines
get their paycheck and then you know
just
that that's the the extent of their
contributions
uh and and it was incredible for me to
see how integral every one of our actors
was to the creating of the movie
and
the movie really was shaped with them
and each of them brought their
personalities whether it was kelly
in that prayer just saying
listen i have a complicated relationship
with sort of like this idea of a higher
power and i would love to
if i were to go into a place like this
and if i were to make a prayer i would
have so much hesitation i would i would
have
so much
um
i wouldn't be able to really just make a
brain i would need to have a dialogue
with myself or with this potential
entity and she did it and whether it was
nora everyone
really just brought the i think also
because they connected with the movie so
much they were so moved that we had an
all-asian cast and there was just so
many things that
made their their connection to the film
really meaningful
and to me it was just incredible to see
how much the the film evolved from all
of our interactions on the on the booth
uh
it really was like they brought it to
life in in in a way that that none of us
could and it was truly beautiful to
watch you know by the way i mean most of
if well
90 at least of the recordings in the
film were done at home so we got to you
know see everybody's you know closets
and you know bathrooms or wherever
they're recording and
uh
daniel day kim there was one amazing
session with daniel daycamp where he it
just every line was it was an
embarrassment of riches everything was
amazing and we got it back and it did
not record it was absolutely unusable so
we had to go back to den and be like um
because
and
because the actors actually
were the ones who had to set it up like
we sent them a mic and you know our our
team would get on with them and help
them set it up but they had to do it you
know because this is a hideakovid and so
it you know it added extra anxiety to
every recording session because we were
you know they're the ones that had to
set up the and get the camera there and
you know there's a lot of that and and
luckily danny he's daniel's so good he
was absolutely and we just did it again
and he was equally brilliant that's
amazing well
it's been
fabulous talking to you about this film
and as all the films of really amazing
insight into everything that's been
nominated this year
congratulations to all the filmmakers
it's been an amazing chat
thank you
thank you
so i'd like to invite the filmmakers up
on stage and bonnie could you come up
and we could take a picture but thank
you so much everyone for coming today
thank you for coming to oscar week
animated features
please look out for an email with a
survey we would love to hear from you
and your responses help us obtain grants
which fund programs like oscar week
[Music]
let's
dial down the audio just a little bit
i think i think what i meant was you
don't have to watch it meaning you can
just be in the ballpark
but i think
what i was wondering is why was i
pushing up the uh
the game so much
so maybe around -20 would be good
ok
good yeah
do you want these cards
for my camera
you